[Music]
the womb is a trap
philip thought to himself he caught its
reflection in a shop window and slowed
his pace
taking in his furrowed brow his stooped
shoulders
the trap was pressing down
bonnie was already naked when she
answered his knock he peeled off his
pants without a word
and followed the promise of her
bottomless gaze
she lay on the sheets afternoon light
making a triangle across her flat belly
she smoked and didn't look at him judy's
pregnant
he hadn't really meant to say it out
loud but there it was
echoing among the sounds of the traffic
from the street below
and he swung his legs over the side of
the bed and reached down for his socks
and i don't know what to do about it
your part's already done champ
she smirked as she watched the smoke
coils hanging in the air
[ __ ] you it's not funny you know judy
she'll expect marriage and happy family
life and all that
bonnie sighed and crushed her cigarette
into the ashtray on the nightstand
why are you telling me this phil i don't
know maybe i should marry her
carry on the family line or something
she got out of bed and slithered into a
silk robe
this doesn't much concern me you know
i've been [ __ ] you for almost as long
as judy and i have been together
you've been [ __ ] others for almost
that long whether you're married or not
isn't gonna stop you from [ __ ] me or
anyone else so why drop all your angst
on me today
her hands were on her hips and her face
was a perfect mask of bored contempt
philip buttoned his shirt savagely okay
sorry
just thought you might have some advice
for a friend
bonnie glided over to the bedroom door
and stood on the threshold
clearly ushering him out i advise you to
quit bothering me with your [ __ ] you
want to [ __ ] come on by you want a [ __ ]
call your therapist
phil stomped the three blocks back to
work hands jammed in his pockets
in the elevator he stared at his
reflection again noting the dark circles
under his eyes
his ever more sloping posture he didn't
know why he had told bonnie anything
for the rest of the afternoon he simply
sat in his office with the door closed
staring at the computer screen as if his
own thoughts were projected there
when the clock finally struck five phil
shrugged into his jacket
and drifted out of the building
robotically wishing his co-workers a
good weekend
his walk home was just as automatic but
halfway there he found himself standing
in front of a glass door
emblazoned with three gold spheres a
bell
jingled as he pushed it open help you
the woman behind the counter was
white-haired and regal with pale
searching eyes
he approached his movement's molasses
thick the jewelry in the case was a riot
of color
all seductive winks and fragmented
images his finger tracked along the rows
of diamond rings
that one he said it looked much like the
others
very good choice the woman said bending
at the knee to slide the blue velvet box
from its place in the lineup
she'll just love it i suppose the corner
of the woman's mouth curled upwards
you don't sound so sure about this she
put the box on the counter and peered up
at him from beneath her lashes
i'm just nervous i guess of course
phil freed the ring from its plush
prison and gave it a perfunctory once
over
it was a solitaire ring with a brilliant
cut stone and a thin
white gold band it seemed adequate
classic even
he noticed as he moved the ring back and
forth the diamond flashing and then
darkening
he caught a glimpse of his own haggard
face in the stone's depths before it
disappeared again
how much the woman chuckled normally
that would be three but i like your
decisiveness
25. phil handed over his credit card
the money didn't concern him the
implications of that tiny white gold
shackle did
he slipped the velvet box into his
jacket pocket and left without another
word
judy was arriving home just as he did
clad in her hospital greens and carrying
a plastic grocery bag in each hand
she greeted him with a smile and a kiss
on the cheek as he opened the door to
the apartment building
i got a couple stakes for tonight
thought you'd like that she said her
bags creaking as she fumbled around for
her keys
sounds good i'd actually love a cocktail
though if you could fix me one
she held the apartment door open with
her butt as he went past her
sure baby let me put all this stuff down
first
phil downed one cocktail in a single
gulp and then moved on to a second
the smell of steaks frying permeated the
apartment a secretive bloody tang
the tv was on and he sat on the couch
looking at it drinking hand
but nothing on the screen was making any
sense to him at all
judy called him to dinner and he turned
it off he had a third drink and then a
fourth
he had taken off his jacket and slung it
across the recliner
but he could still see the square
protrusion in the pocket like the
rectangle of dirt covering a fresh grave
judy for her part didn't seem to notice
anything amiss
humming as she washed the dinner dishes
prattling on about some funny incident
at work
he half listened smiled where he was
supposed to
after a while she settled on the sofa
with her tablet her pleasant face lit by
its blue glow
he let another two hours pass before he
glanced at her
his heartbeat was a death knell judy
she looked up i have something for you
he reached across and pulled his jacket
into his lap
judy watched him sweetly curious when he
pulled out the ring box she sat up
straighter and her eyes filled with
tears
she let her tablet slide off to the side
he opened the box and held it out toward
her
an offering will you marry me
he felt as though he was speaking around
a mouthful of sand her tears spilled
over and she laughed a girlish laugh
a sound like a tingling bell oh philip
you didn't have to
because of the baby and everything he
realized he was still holding the ring
box in one
outstretched hand like an idiot he took
the ring out and slid over to her
taking her hand to put it on her finger
it's not because of that he said
i just wanted to i felt like it was time
she stared down at the ring with
something like rapture then met his eyes
it's beautiful phil and yes i will i
love you
she threw her arms around his neck and
kissed his forehead his ear the corner
of his mouth
her tears left salty dampness on his
skin love you too judy
he returned her kisses hugged her
tightly around the waist
the ring sparkled in his peripheral
vision in the reflected light from the
tv screen the stone almost seemed to
turn black
he was still awake several hours after
judy had fallen asleep beside him
she had been especially amorous after
his proposal and phil had tried but the
four cocktails and the thoughts of his
impending marriage and the shitty day
he'd had
conspired to prevent even a glimmering
of an erection
he'd apologized shame-faced but of
course judy had forgiven him
she always forgave him in the moonlight
streaming in through the blinds he could
see her hands folded across her stomach
see the slyly winking diamond on her
finger underneath that stone
underneath her folded hands a piece of
him was growing
he shifted his position on the bed and
punched his pillow into a more amenable
shape
he imagined judy's belly inflating in
seconds like a balloon attached to a
helium tank
and then exploding in a rain of blood
and gobbets of flesh
scowling he closed his eyes wondering
what the [ __ ] was wrong with him
judy rolled over in her sleep and her
hand flopped onto his chest
he opened his eyes again the ring was
inches from his face
its facets reflecting the room back at
him in insect vision
as he stared at it he thought he saw a
trickle of dark liquid emerging from it
and snaking its way down judy's finger
he felt wetness on his chest as the
fluid dripped
he picked up her hand between two
fingers and cast it away in disgust
judy stirred but didn't wake phil sat up
and looked down at his bare chest but
there was nothing there judy's hand now
resting on the sheet was clean
on saturdays phil had been in the habit
of going to see bonnie or sometimes
rachel
while judy was working her long shift at
the hospital
today though he slept until several
hours after judy had gone
and by the time he awakened he felt so
dire that leaving the house for any
reason was out of the question
he managed to stay on his feet long
enough to shower and shave
staring at himself and wondering who the
old man in the mirror was
the sound of breaking glass brought his
razor up short
blood bloomed in a thin line across his
jaw
swearing he grabbed for a tissue
pressing it to his face as he stumbled
back into the bedroom
he got his pistol from the nightstand
and slid the drawer closed quietly
the sound had come from the kitchen he
was sure
the silence in the apartment pressed
around his ears like a wool blanket
slanted light painted the hallway as he
crept along feeling vaguely ridiculous
with the gun held shakily out before him
the kitchen was deserted as was the
living room when he peered out across
the bar
he set the gun on the counter and led
out a breath scanning the area for the
source of the sound
there was nothing fallen nothing broken
he snatched open the cabinets and stared
at the rows of gleaming drinking glasses
innocently intact he blinked
the glasses darkened clouded as if a
shadow had passed before the window
and he spun around for a moment he
thought he saw a sort of shimmer
a bright rain of color bursts hanging in
the air when he blinked again they were
gone
he scrubbed at his face scowling when
his hand came away smeared with blood
from his cut
christ he said to the empty apartment
and even his voice sounded
old muffled by the close atmosphere he
had to get out
rachel wasn't surprised to see him but
she wasn't thrilled either
don't you ever call i was just going
stir crazy
haven't been feeling very well phil sat
stiffly on her futon
withering under the gaze of pluto
rachel's imperious maine [ __ ]
poor thing want some tea maybe later
come here he pulled her down into his
lap when she approached
and thrust his hand under her shirt she
pressed her body against his straddling
his legs
the cat jumped off the futon with a
squall
15 minutes later phil was hunched at one
end of the futon his pants back on but
still unbuttoned
a cup of tea growing cold in his hand
pluto had returned to his place
swishing his tail in triumph well you
did say you were sick
rachel's voice was flat sorry he mumbled
i don't know what's wrong with me the
last couple days it's no big deal really
you'd have had to go soon anyway i have
things to do
she was leaning against the wall arms
crossed her skin
like smooth stone yeah so do i
he finished his cold gritty tea and set
the cup on the coffee table
when he stood up his pants sagged and
slid halfway down his ass
rachel smirked as he yanked them up and
buttoned them
for the rest of the afternoon he
wandered the streets not wanting to go
back to the empty apartment
it was a pleasant fall day crisp and
sunny but everywhere he went he felt as
though he was enclosed in a dusky fog
he met the eyes of passersby but their
gazes seemed to slide past him
when he grew tired of walking he ducked
into a coffee shop and sat at the window
nursing a latte and watching the huge
and different world bustling past on the
other side of the glass
did you have a good day today she asked
this every saturday when she came home
he threw his head back and emptied his
beard down his throat does it look like
i had a good day
judy flinched but when her expression
settled there was only concern for him
there
no anger sorry baby i thought you looked
a little sick last night
yeah i think i'm sick his momentary rage
had dissolved
and he felt suddenly exhausted
claustrophobic
probably going to be an early night for
me need me to get you anything
her eagerness to please was giving him a
headache he waved her off and she went
into
the kitchen where he heard glasses
clinking together and the sound of water
running
he put his beer bottle between his legs
inside
for a second he entertained the notion
of going into the kitchen and telling
her about the noises he'd heard earlier
but the desire dwindled as quickly as it
appeared
instead he staggered into the bedroom
and fell asleep without even taking off
his clothes
he awoke a seeming instant later he was
lying on his back
and the room was hot he moved his head
and saw that judy was also on her back
snoring softly beside him her stomach
was an enormous mound beneath the covers
and it was then that he realized that he
was dreaming slowly he reached over and
slipped the sheets off her engorged
belly
distantly he noticed that her diamond
ring was now on his finger
the stone like an obsidian eye the flesh
of her stomach pulsed
phil watched it curious to see what
would emerge but then with the certainty
of dreams he understood
he placed the edge of the diamond
against her belly button and sliced
downward in one swift stroke
a ragged red fissure opened blood
pooling along the lips of the wound like
quivering rubies
inside was a riot of shifting refracted
light illuminating the room like
floodlights in a swimming pool
phil curled his fingers around the edges
of the chasm and pulled
widening the wound intensifying the glow
the brilliance was now so blinding that
he had to turn his head
and when he did he heard a faint sound
of a baby crying very far away
philip awoke for real his heart thudding
his sweaty hair pasted to his forehead
he felt his fingers which were ringless
and a quick glance showed that judy
slept on
her still-flat midriff rising and
falling in a steady rhythm
he swallowed and heard his tongue click
then another sound
a baby crying phil sat up in bed
it could have been coming from one of
the other apartments in the building of
course
but he'd never heard a baby crying in
the building before and it sounded close
he looked down at judy again but she
hadn't moved he slid out of bed
the room seemed darker than usual with
barely enough moonlight to see by
and he felt assaulted by some gray
miasma whose tendrils insinuated
themselves into his nose and mouth
the crying grew louder and higher
pitched as he made his way toward the
kitchen
he couldn't believe that judy hadn't
heard it too and the fact that she
hadn't made him think that perhaps he
was still dreaming
but no everything around him was real
and solid and he could feel the wood
floors slick beneath his feet the cold
walls beneath his fingers
the kitchen was empty but the sound of
the baby crying was very loud
in the perfect square of the window the
moonlight was a solid featureless white
the air felt suspended phil waited
hardly remembering to breathe
the baby keened and wailed the sound
coming from everywhere at once
he covered his ears but he still heard
it now as intimate as a sigh
the moonlight around him was flickering
a living thing
he didn't know how long he stood there
the baby's cries eventually waned like a
fading radio signal and phil dropped his
hands to his sides
it took a while before he was able to
place one foot in front of the other
to push against the air that hemmed him
in the hallway before him seemed to
stretch into forever
its angles skewed and fractured he
walked it like a blind man
keeping his arms extended for balance
staggering this way and that
he opened the bedroom door the darkness
was nearly complete and he strained to
sea
swirling clouds moved before his eyes
revealing the bedroom as he had left it
except that judy was standing very still
at the foot of the bed
staring at him no not judy something
else
phil froze it was a woman or the
likeness of one
her hair was white and hung in straight
curtains on either side of her face
partly obscuring it even so phil
couldn't help but feel that she was
familiar somehow
her face had barely their memory she was
naked and her breasts were pale globes
that sat atop a monstrously pregnant
belly
it was here that phil's comprehension of
what he was seeing began to break down
for her stomach looked as though it was
made of a polished faceted diamond
all glinting prisms below the diamond
was simply a smear of white
that suggested legs though at their
extremities they seemed to drip
showers of falling stars that sizzled
and vanished into the floor beneath her
but all of that wasn't the worst for
phil could see that there was some small
squirming thing moving inside the
diamond in her belly
something that seemed to be staring out
at him with two shining black eyes
he thought he screamed but he couldn't
have because judy didn't stir
the apparition hovered there for no more
than a few seconds
but to fill it looked like time had
stopped the thing
inside her belly pressed closer against
its prison and the facets of the diamond
distorted its face into horrible
geometric puzzle pieces
still it stared its eyes like holes
phil didn't see it fade or wink out of
existence it was suddenly just not there
anymore
he blinked and let out a ragged breath
the room appeared completely normal
the objects becoming a little more
distinct as the first rays of dawn began
to creep
in through the blinds judy slept
peacefully oblivious
he stood very still for a long time
watching listening
starting at the slightest sound he stood
this way until morning had broken fully
and the room was filled with a pleasing
diffused light
at long last when nothing happened at
all phil moved slowly to the bed and
settled in beside judy
resisting the childlike urge to pull the
covers over his head
he stared at the ceiling for what seemed
like hours thinking he would never be
able to fall asleep again after what he
had seen
he was still thinking this when he
drifted into unconsciousness
everything was in pieces when phil
opened his eyes reality painted on
fragments
for a long time he couldn't understand
what he was seeing
there were the walls of his bedroom and
the ceiling but they were all awry
the angle is a crazy patchwork here was
a glimpse of the blue comforter
there the sliver of a lampshade as he
struggled to fit the fragments of the
picture together
he noticed fractions of flesh the curve
of a jawline the arch of an eyebrow
then suddenly he was in motion his body
lifted as though it was no more than an
atom's weight
he threw out his arms to steady himself
but they were boxed in
and his legs were likewise useless
folded painfully beneath him
all at once the fragments turned
completely flesh-colored and then for a
moment he saw nothing but a gigantic ice
blue eye
staring at him like the eye of a god
another motion and he realized that he
was looking into judy's face
enormous above him her expression
uncharacteristically hard and venomous
he thought he screamed but he heard no
sound he remembered his dream from the
night before
and this seemed all of a piece with it
but also achingly real
as the white-haired woman standing by
his bed had been
he realized with a start that he was
seeing his fiancee from the perspective
of the ring upon her finger
the ring he had so carelessly bought the
shackle that would tie him to her
symbolically
just as the creature growing inside of
her tied him to her biologically
the huge fragmented woman above him gave
a terrible smile
a wide-toothed rictus and then he was
moving again lower and lower
watching her body flash past him in a
series of triangular flickers
then it was all flesh again growing
larger and larger in his vision
and as the ring moved closer he realized
he was now poised just above her belly
the midline of her abdomen is stark as
an ink line on white paper
there was very little resistance as the
diamond penetrated the skin
for a moment phil saw nothing but red
and then the brilliant play of the
stone's light blinded him
it was a long-shadowed late afternoon
and julia was staring duly into the
refrigerator
not hungry but feeling as though she
should make something or eat something
just to be going through the motions of
a normal task
from outside there was a whispery crunch
as of someone moving through the carpet
of fallen leaves in the backyard
julia turned wondering if it was some
early trick-or-treater approaching from
the rear
or a teenage curiosity seeker on a dare
come to see the house on the fateful
anniversary
she moved to the window in the middle of
the backyard was an old swing set that
scott had always played on as a child
next to it was a black goat standing
upright
wearing a drooping red bell collar furry
horns twisted
black bead eyes motionless the goat had
a human hand
where one of its hooves should have been
julia put her own hand to her mouth
the goat stood looking toward her and
not moving she didn't know if it could
see her or not
she almost called for bill but then
remembered that he was gone of course
the last echo of him is shouted
expletive in the roar of a car
engine julia was alone hesitantly she
went to the back door and peered through
the curtains
the goat was still there but it seemed
to have shifted its weight
and as she watched it turned its horned
head to one side
as though considering a course of action
scott
she said under her breath his name like
a talisman
she turned the knob and opened the door
before she could step outside
before she could repeat the name the
goat had turned and dashed awkwardly off
into the shrubbery
leaving a panicked flurry of crisp red
leaves in its wake julia stood on the
threshold for a very long time
staring at the space where the goat had
been the longer she stood there the more
she was able to tell herself that she
had seen nothing but her own wishful
illusions
but she was not able to completely
convince herself
and so as night began to close in and
the faint laughter and squeals of
children began to float on the frosted
air
julia went back inside and called the
police
inspector jim wright was almost ready to
go off duty but he took the call and
agreed to stop by the langley house on
his way home
whatever julia langley had seen it had
upset her immensely
and even if it was just a sick prank
wright felt compelled to check it out
he liked julia a great deal and
genuinely felt for her that business a
year ago had been terribly ugly
when he got to the house julia was
composed though her eyes were a little
red
thanks for coming she said and offered
him coffee which he accepted
while she went to make it wright
wandered out the back door and made a
slow circuit of the yard
it was full dark now of course but julia
had turned on the floodlights mounted on
the house's eaves
and they bathed the area in a stark
white glow
even so there was nothing to see the
space near the swing set where mrs
langley had seen the goat
was unremarkable save for a few trodden
leaves
wright tretched back to the house and
slid into a chair at the kitchen table
julia placed a steaming mug in front of
him and gave him a rueful smile before
sitting down herself
i'm perfectly willing to accept that i
imagine the whole thing she said without
any prompting from him
i don't think i did but maybe the stress
is getting to me more than i realize
where's bill did he see it julia's gaze
was flat over
the rim of her cup i told him to leave
wright sat back in his chair when was
this two days ago
so under stress is something of an
understatement right thought
not only was it halloween the first
anniversary of her son's disappearance
but now this
mrs langley julia i know this isn't
really my business
but she gave him that sad little smile
again
christ jim after all you've done for me
you're like family don't worry about
getting into my business
you know there was never any real
evidence that bill had anything to do
with it
i know it wasn't just about the
disappearance or about that girl
her voice on the last word was hard as
diamond dust
clearly she still suspected zoe of
something even if the police had
released her
julia took another sip of her coffee i
just felt like bill was never fully on
board you know
sometimes i thought well it was almost
like he didn't really want to find scott
this did not surprise wright as much as
it probably should have
scott's disappearance had brought forth
some scandalous accusations against bill
and even if they weren't true the stench
of them was hard to erase
wright had to admit he felt a little
sorry for the guy though he never would
have said as much
to julia she was really the one getting
the worst deal out of all this
after all she lost her son her husband
her peace of mind
and now it seemed like somebody was
fooling around in her backyard
trying to make the whole thing into a
joke wright leaned forward getting down
to business
so you saw this person through the
window yes i saw him clearly
he ran off before i could get outside
her gaze drifted to the window above the
sink which was now a dark rectangle
partially concealed by curtains it was
the same costume scott was wearing when
he disappeared
she said quietly still not looking at
him i remember it because the horns were
crooked
one slightly bigger than the other and
the bell collar was red
and of course one of the hooves was
missing her voice shook a little but she
held herself together
she had told him about the goat's human
hand on the phone and this was the
detail that most disturbed him
scott langley had disappeared on
halloween night exactly one year before
he had been dressed as one of the three
billy goats gruff his girlfriend zoe was
the troll
while their two friends alan and tiffany
played the parts of the other two goats
after scott's disappearance one of the
only traces of him found by police
was a single furry hoof from the goat
costume
the inside of it had been streaked with
blood it had been found floating near
the edge of the muddy stream
under the wood burrow bridge two days
after scott had gone missing
julia was looking across the table at
him now her eyes deep pools of rage and
sorrow in her otherwise calm face
i don't know what all this means she
said wright knew she wanted to believe
she'd seen scott out there in her
backyard
but he also knew that she was realistic
enough to understand that her son was
probably dead
julia was justifiably upset but she
wasn't delusional
so if the person in the goat suit had
really been there and if it wasn't scott
then who was it
some kid with a morbid fascination with
the case who was getting his jollies out
of toying with a grieving woman
or someone who knew exactly what had
happened to scott that night
it was the same costume scott was
wearing i remember it
memory was a funny thing right thought
it was possible all this was a fantasy
or a misunderstanding
but until further notice he was going to
operate on the assumption that julia had
stared into the masked face of her son's
killer
technically the langley case was still
open though wright had been the only one
doing any work on it for the past four
months
he had taken the files home after his
stop at julia's house
and planned to look over them for the
rest of the evening he had also phoned
back to his office
telling the night officer to be on alert
for any strange reports of a man in a
black goat suit wearing only one glove
wright made more coffee and settled onto
the sofa in his small but neat living
room
his cat agatha purred and rubbed against
his leg then jumped up beside him and
promptly dozed off
the apartment was otherwise quiet the
only sounds the far away hum
of traffic and the tick of the clock on
the mantle the exact facts of the
langley case were worryingly ambiguous
on halloween night of 2009 scott langley
had gone to a costume party at the home
of a vague acquaintance
susan hawthorne accompanying him to the
party was his girlfriend of 18 months
zoe beamish and two other friends alan
young and tiffany grandy
scott and zoe had gone to the party in
zoe's car a 2001 nissan altima
allen and tiffany had gone and allen's
battered forward
at around 9 45 pm according to alan and
tiffany who had corroborated each
other's stories
the four of them had left the party and
driven to woodboro bridge
which was a fairly common hangout they
drove there in their separate cars
they had brought along some beers from
the party and after a bit of coaxing
admitted to possessing some marijuana as
well
the four friends talked drank and smoked
for more than an hour still clad in
their halloween costumes
at around quarter to 11 scott appeared
to be getting intoxicated
and he and zoe began to argue both alan
and tiffany claimed that scott made
accusations of infidelity toward zoe
which she denied
he became verbally abusive but allen was
able to calm him down
though according to him scott still
seemed morose
the mood of the get-together had soured
so alan and tiffany left just before
midnight
both under the impression that scott and
zoe would make up and then follow them
back to the party at the hawthorne house
that a phone call confirmed was still in
full swing
alan and tiffany arrived back at the
halloween party at about 12 30 according
to witnesses
they did not immediately worry when
scott and zoe did not arrive
though tiffany phoned zoe and got no
answer finally at 10 to 1 in the morning
zoe returned tiffany's call she sounded
strange and very upset
and claimed scott had been acting
bizarrely and had disappeared into the
woods
she said she had looked for him but
after 15 minutes of calling and
wandering around the muddy banks
she left him to fend for himself and
drove off her parents confirmed zoe
arrived home shortly after 1 20 am
when scott had not returned home by the
following morning his mother called zoe
and all her son's other friends
then called local hospitals coming up
empty she finally reported his
disappearance to police
at this point wright looked up from his
files staring absently at the wall and
stroking the head of his sleeping feline
he remembered julia's initial phone call
much like today she had seemed tight
voiced but calm
though he could sense the underlying
panic threatening to spiral up and
overtake her
the case had initially seemed cut and
dried scott was 17
he'd had a fight with his girlfriend he
was out drinking and smoking dope with
his friends
he had probably just gone off and slept
in the woods or at the home of a friend
his mother didn't know about
wright had told julia langley all this
in order to reassure her
but even then he had the disquieting
sensation that there was more to the
boy's disappearance than met the eye
julia certainly seemed to think so
despite his attempts to minimize her
fears she would not be mollified
and seemed to resent his efforts to calm
her
wright had begun an investigation
various clues collected over the course
of the next few days
seemed to strengthen wright's hunch
about the case droplets of blood that
proved to be scots were found in the mud
near the bank of the stream
as well as on the wooden slats of
woodboro bridge a small knife also
discovered in the mud had a streak of
scots blood on the blade
its handle contained a partial
fingerprint but its owner could not be
determined
scott's blood though only a few spots of
it was found in the trunk of zoe's car
the glove of scott's goat costume was
discovered near the stream
as though it had been tossed off the
overhanging bridge wright had brought
dogs in to cover the area and they had
followed ascent another mile from the
site where the glove was found
but then lost the trail no other trace
of scott turned up after that
at julia's insistence wright had
searched scott's bedroom watching the
team pick meticulously through the
detritus of an average 17 year old boy's
life
nothing was found to indicate that scott
had been depressed or considering
suicide
no phone numbers or addresses of
previously unknown friends were
discovered
the only significant piece of the puzzle
was a plain black diary that looked
fairly new and only had a few entries in
it
the final entry dated october 30th 2009
read
found out about z and my dad can't
believe if it's true
they might do something if they know i
know about it z has been acting crazy
and strange and now i know why
when asked about this diary entry both
zoe beamish and scott's father bill
langley vehemently denied any
relationship between them
zoe also denied having anything to do
with scott's disappearance
and claimed she had no idea how scott's
blood might have gotten into the trunk
of her car
or onto the mud near the bank of the
stream
wright leaned back on the sofa rubbing
his eyes this was the kind of case he
hated
seemingly tauntingly simple and yet
riddled with vague clues and unknown
motivations
he had questioned zoe beemish and bill
langley himself and while going in he
had wanted to dismiss their alleged
affairs the over-dramatic fantasies of a
jealous teenage boy
wright found he couldn't quite discredit
the story entirely
bill langley in particular seemed a
little off a little secretive
wright could easily see how julia had
gotten the idea that bill was not
especially diligent in wanting to track
down his son
and zoe was an enigma all on her own
careening from veturative diatribes
about scott's character
to tearful proclamations of undying love
to flat-eyed emotionless silence
wright was sure he had earned more than
a few ulcers during the few months when
the investigation was hottest
so where did things stand now if julia
was to be believed
and wright thought she was at least for
the present someone wearing scott's
black goat costume was lurking around in
her yard for some unknown purpose
it could have been scott himself of
course but wright doubted it even if the
kid was still alive which was unlikely
where on earth had he been all this time
and why would he want to torment his
mother that way
more likely something stranger was going
on the person in the goat suit might
also ben scott's father bill
or even zoe who was taller than average
for a girl
alan and tiffany were also distinct
candidates though they had been nothing
but cooperative during the entire
investigation
and didn't seem like the types of kids
who would pull a horrid stunt like this
and then there was also the remote
possibility that scott had stormed off
into the woods that night and into the
path of some random psycho
the kind of guy who would kill a nice 17
year old kid for no reason at all
and then parade around in the kid's
costume to satisfy some of his freak
urges
if this was the case then julia langley
herself might be in danger
wright would have to keep a close eye on
her
ray had left julia locked all the doors
and windows tightly
drew all the blinds and curtains and
extinguished the front porch lights to
discourage trick-or-treaters from
pounding on the door
although she did not know it everything
that had been going through wright's
mind about the case had also gone
through hers
in much the same order but at a more
feverish pace
she had no idea what the person she had
seen wanted from her but she couldn't
shake the feeling that it might be a
warning or even a threat
she had to admit to herself that when
she'd first seen the goat standing out
by the swing set
she had immediately thought it was scott
who wouldn't have but after he
it had turned to run away she got the
distinct impression that the goat did
not move as scott had
her son had always been live and
graceful with a gazelle-like lope to his
walk
the person in the goat suit had seemed
slightly bulkier clumsy
as though not in complete control of his
limbs part of this might have been due
to the cumbersome dimensions of the
costume but not all of it
the fact that julia couldn't think of
anyone who moved the way the goat had
filled her with creeping unease she sat
in the living room the tv on but muted
and watched the closed curtains as if
she could see through them imagining the
black goat with the twisted horns and
the human hand
standing out there in the dark forming a
shadowy maypole for costumed children
running laughingly around it
in the whirl of a great pagan ceremony
this vision was so intense that at last
she rose quickly to her feet and swept
the curtains aside
but the yard was empty and the cheery
orange light from the jack-o-lanterns
lining the porches on the opposite side
of the street
wright's cell phone chimed at a little
past 11 pm he had dozed off sitting up
on the sofa
files still spread across his lap his
hand resting loosely on agatha's head
at the sound of the phone he snapped
instantly awake startling the cat so
much that she yelled and leaped to the
floor
fixing him with a withering glare before
sauntering off with her tail in the air
wright brought the phone to his ear yes
hey jim this might be nothing but one of
the officers patrolling near that
walgreens on 44th
said he thought he saw someone in a
furry costume with a red collar getting
into a black ford mustang that had been
sitting in the parking lot
wright's heart rate jumped that
drugstore was less than three blocks
from the house julia langley now lived
in alone
did he get the plate sure did he was
gonna follow the car too but it had
taken the highway exit was long gone by
the time the officer got turned around
the plate numbers 4e37 registered to a
daryl shaughnessy
residence at 1884 emerald avenue
bridgeton
the name didn't ring a bell but wright's
heart was still pounding
it was the first lead they'd had in
months had the bridgeton police been
alerted yeah i spoke to an inspector
over there named sherry rayburn
if you want to ride out with her when
she goes to pay them a visit she'll
expect you by midnight
think you can make it by then are you
kidding i'm halfway out the door already
this was not entirely true in actuality
he was trying to straighten up the files
that had slid off his lap in his
excitement
and simultaneously searching for his
shoes which seemed to have been sucked
into the black vortex beneath the couch
give me her number i'll call her when
i'm on the road wright wrote the number
on the edge of a manila folder when the
night
officer gave it to him then thanked him
for calling and rang off
he found his shoes at last and slipped
into them then pulled his keys out from
where they had jammed in his pocket
he dialed rayburn's number as he left
the house and when she answered he gave
her a brief rundown of the langley case
explaining that this daryl shaughnessy
was just a person of interest at this
point
whether he was the man in the costume or
not
after the call he sat in his car for a
few moments wondering if he should phone
julia to let her know what was going on
it seemed cruel to build her hopes up
when all this might turn out to be a big
dead end
besides that it was getting late and she
might have already gone to bed
but he hesitated only a moment before
deciding that if it was his own child
who was missing
he would want to know about every
scintilla of police work being done to
find him
damn the hour or the false hopes he
scrolled to her number and called
as soon as the headlights of the police
cruiser washed over the driveway at 1884
emerald
wright had a feeling this was the place
he didn't see a black mustang but the
garage door was closed and he could see
the flickering blue light of a
television coming from behind the
curtains
indicating someone was home there was a
large carved pumpkin sitting on the
front porch
already starting to go punky around the
cut edges there was no light inside it
but wright could see that it had been
sloppily carved into a leering devil's
face
with a large rusty steak knife
protruding from its head in an oddly
jaunty way
as they mounted the wooden porch steps
rayburn in the lead wright saw the
twitch of a curtain out of the corner of
his eyes
rayburn knocked on the door firmly
announcing bridgton police please open
up
for a long moment wright wondered if
anyone was going to answer rayburn
knocked again
finally the door opened a crack
revealing a shadowed figure wearing a
blue lit aura from the television
what do you want do you or someone in
this house drive a black ford mustang
tag number 4e37ha
rayburn asked the shadow fidgeted it was
clearly male a large form with vaguely
lumpy proportions
wright noticed that despite his large
size his movements were curiously
furtive
like those of a bashful child i can't
drive
the figure said in a small voice we're
looking for daryl shaughnessy rayburn
said
at this the figure straightened and
backed up a few steps opening the door
wider
my cousin the voice said in a much
brighter tone almost one of excitement
or pride
now that the door was opened fully
wright could see another figure perched
on the edge of the sofa
a rangy boy and ragged jeans and an
orange t-shirt that said costume across
the front
in bold black letters black and white
images of a heavily brown bella lugosi
pulsed across the tv screen
wright recognized the film as white
zombie there was a bowl of candy on the
table next to the sofa
half filled with empty wrappers the boy
presumably daryl got up from the couch
and slowly approached them
even in the dark wright caught the dirty
look daryl flashed at his cousin
the cousin evidently saw it too for he
flinched as if struck
now that wright had a better view of the
person who had opened the door
he could see that it was just a kid 14
or 15 at most
and that he appeared to have some sort
of mental impairment
wright immediately felt a surge of pity
for the boy did he know that his beloved
cousin might be a murderer
can i help you daryl said now leaning in
the doorway
he was quite a handsome young man with
longish blonde curls and brown eyes like
a puppies
he looked nervous and more than a little
cocky you're daryl shaughnessy rayburn
asked
yes was it your black mustang parked in
the lot at the walgreens on 44th avenue
this evening at approximately 10 25 pm
he paused as if he wasn't going to reply
but then his face split into a crooked
grin
yeah i took junior here
trick-or-treating and i was waiting for
him there
kind of a long way to go just for
trick-or-treating right observed
daryl shrugged not much action around
here you get better candy in the nicer
neighborhood you know
do you know scott langley rayburn asked
abruptly
wright saw daryl hesitate but only for a
second no
he said what costume did your cousin
wear when he went out trick-or-treating
wright asked daryl's brow furrowed they
were rattling him and that was good
um i think it was a horse or a cow or
something rudy loves animals
that grin again but this time less
assured more like the wide rictus of a
fearful chimpanzee
you sure it wasn't a goat wright said
might have been
daryl replied it wasn't a very good
costume where did you get it
it was just an old one we had lying
around wright crossed his arms
you're sure you don't know scott langley
daryl's dark eyes flared
of course i'm sure look is all this
leading to something or are you gonna
piss off and leave me alone
as soon as the words were out of his
mouth he clearly regretted saying them
but to compensate he pressed his lips
together in apparent defiance
let me run down the scenario for you
wright said aware that rudy was standing
close behind daryl's shoulder
eyes wide with terror someone in a goat
costume was seen standing behind the
home of julia langley
julia langley is the mother of scott
langley who disappeared a year ago
wearing a goat costume very similar if
not identical
to the one this person was wearing this
person was then seen getting into a
black mustang registered to you mr
shaughnessy
am i making myself quite clear daryl
just pressed his lips together tighter
but behind him the cousin began to wail
i just put on the costume because daryl
told me to
the kid said between tears i didn't know
i was doing anything wrong
shut up rudy daryl snarled which only
made the kid cry harder
wright looked straight into daryl's dark
eyes did you kill scott langley he asked
quietly
no he dropped his gaze from rights but
then sought it out again
no i didn't kill scott do you know who
did
perhaps inadvertently wright glanced at
rudy who was shaking like a leaf over
his cousin's shoulder
was daryl protecting his mentally
challenged relative
daryl was staring at the two inspectors
lip twitching
clearly mulling something over wright
silently coached him
that's right shaughnessy he thought just
tell us everything and get it over with
at last he seemed to have come to a
decision come in
he mumbled upstairs first room on the
left
wright and rayburn exchanged glances
then simultaneously unclipped their
pieces from their belts
rudy was trembling so violently that
wright expected him to break into
fragments
but daryl just looked resigned you won't
need those
he said raising his hands in the air
with just a twinge of mockery
we're all unarmed we'll keep them handy
if it's all the same to you
rayburn said stepping over the threshold
daryl shrugged again
neither of the boys moved as the
inspectors made their way slowly into
the living room
could one of you tell me where the
lights are please rayburn said
rudy started to move toward them but
rayburn barks stay where you are
rudy froze with a tiny shriek tears
streaming down his cheeks a long line of
snot dangling from one nostril
right hoped the poor kid didn't die of a
heart attack on the spot
daryl pointed to a plate on the wall
near the kitchen and rayburn sidled over
and flicked on all the switches
everyone blinked for a few moments
adjusting to the glare
the living room looked flat and dingy
under the cheap ceiling fixtures like an
abandoned stage set
the lights over the stairs had also come
on and wright was glad of that
he didn't like to admit it but the whole
scene was beginning to freak him out a
bit
this sad dirty little house out in the
sticks the two boys staring up at him
with their respectively blubbering and
unreadable faces
bella lugosi glaring out from the tv
screen as if he too was watching and
weighing in on the proceedings
not to mention the anxiety over what
they would find in that room upstairs
he had a feeling that this halloween
might give him enough nightmares to last
for a lifetime
rayburn went first since it was her
jurisdiction and when she had reached
the top of the stairs in the long
darkened hallway it led onto
she felt around along the wall looking
for another light switch
after a moment she found it and the hall
was flooded with a sickly yellow glow
that put right in mind of insect lights
or of the slowly rotting flesh of the
carved jack-o-lantern outside
there were three doors one of which was
open right could see a pie wedge of
chipped gray linoleum
and the edge of a pink porcelain bathtub
they approached the first door
hands on their guns the sound from the
television was muted but still drifted
up the stairs with eerie strains of
distorted organ
rayburn glanced at him and he nodded she
placed her hand on the doorknob held it
there for a moment
then turned it and slammed the door
inward in one fluid motion
the room within was dark but in the
faint glow from the hallway right could
make out the unmistakable form of a
human being
sprawled across the bed there was a
stale scent in the room
the sour odor of unwashed clothes a tang
of sweat
even a very slight metallic whiff of
blood wright had a second to ponder and
be grateful for the lack of a strong
decay smell
before rayburn flipped on the lights
there was indeed a figure on the bed
a gangly boy of late teenage years black
hair falling upon the pillow
his back was turned toward them and he
was very still
as right stared he caught a glimpse of
glossy black out of the corner of his
eye
he turned his head slightly in a ratty
old armchair in the corner was piled a
misshapen mass of shimmering ebony fur
in a flash wright had made out the
shapes of gray cloven hooves
and even caught a glimpse of red that
was presumably the collar with its
silver bell
the way the costume sat upon the chair
made right assume that the goat's horned
head was underneath the folds of the
body portion
rayburn took a few steps toward the bed
and as she did there came a thick snort
like an animal rooting in the ground and
she immediately brought her gun up to
chest level
right did too a reflex born of long
practice
but then he noticed that the supposed
corpse on the bed had moved
in seconds he found himself staring down
his gun barrel at a bearded young man
sitting halfway up on the bed blinking
confusedly
hey what's going on wright lowered his
weapon
though not completely scott langley he
asked
but even before he said it he knew that
it was despite the beard and the
darkened hair
he had seen enough photos of the boy to
recognize those wide green eyes
and that bony hawk-like nose what who
the boy sat up fully now scratching at a
scraggly beard
his gaze darting left and right rayburn
had partially lowered her weapon as well
but she was looking at him quizzically
as if to say yeah what is going on have
you lost your mind
you're scott langley wright said your
mother's been going crazy looking for
you
i'm william steyer you can check my
driver's license if you want it's in my
pants pocket
he pointed to a pile of clothes on the
floor with a trembling finger
wright finally re-holstered his weapon
drop the act i know who you are
was the goat suit tonight your idea i
don't know what you're talking about he
muttered but he could not meet wright's
gays
i'd like you to come with us now wright
said gently
it was also surreal talking to this kid
who he had been expecting to find
rotting in a ditch somewhere for the
past 12 months
for a second he was almost convinced he
had made a mistake but no
he thought looking at the boy's thin
angular face so like his mother's
this was definitely scott am i being
arrested for something
the kid said we're just gonna have a
talk for now
right said i'm going to call your mother
too have her come down
she'll be happy to see you but you're
gonna have a hell of a lot of explaining
to do
julia sat in the bear police station
interrogation room listening to her son
with disbelief
it was strange enough that he was
sitting there before her bearded and
considerably thinner
but unmistakably scott but the story he
was telling was equally unbelievable
diabolical even what did you do for
money
wright was asking scott shrugged i had
some saved up and i borrowed some from
daryl
plus i sold some stuff once i got to
daryl's house and got my new driver's
license i got a job at the restaurant
daryl manages
julia sat back in her chair and regarded
him bleakly
you weren't planning on coming back he
wouldn't look at her
no i was supposed to be dead remember
what i don't understand is why
wright said why go to such elaborate
lengths because you were the one who
spilled your blood in the trunk of zoe's
car weren't you
and you were the one who made sure alan
and tiffany heard you arguing under the
bridge
you even left the glove of the costume
in the stream for us to find
and deliberately wrote that diary entry
to cast suspicion on zoe and your father
why go to all that trouble scott was
looking down at his hands
his shoulders were slumped i loved zoey
a lot you know
and to think of her and my dad julia saw
him shudder and she almost hated him in
that second
for making her picture the scenario as
he was undoubtedly picturing it
after a long pause scott continued i
just went a little crazy you know and
then it was too late to turn back to
undo it
at first i actually thought about
killing them both it would have been
easy to do
but it wasn't enough i wanted them to
suffer i wanted everyone to know
i thought even if i can't get them
convicted for killing me
at least they'll be suspects and
everything would come out in the press
and they wouldn't be able to show their
faces again
in this julia thought his plot had been
successful bill had lost his job and
several friends
even before julia had kicked him out and
last she heard zoe had had to move out
of town under the cloud of suspicion
that still hung over her
during scott's entire speech his thin
frame had barely moved
his gaze had not risen and what about me
scott
julia said did you think how this would
affect me
i wasn't even thinking about you scott
suddenly raised his head and looked at
his mother
his eyes were blazing and ringed with
red the only thing i thought was if dad
was doing that and you didn't know about
it then you were sort of responsible too
for letting it happen there was another
pause in which scott's ragged breathing
could be clearly heard
at last wright broke the silence and
what about tonight scott
the boy finally locked eyes with the
inspector i thought everyone was
forgetting about it
he said flatly zoe and my father were
walking around free
nothing had been in the papers for a
while i didn't want to wear the costume
myself in case i got caught
but daryl's cousin isn't too bright he
would do whatever we said
he didn't know who i was or anything
about the case i wanted someone who
didn't have any connection with scott
langley he scratched at his beard
nervously
julia was disturbed at how he could
speak of himself in the third person so
casually
as if his former identity had simply
been an old skin he'd since shed
she also wondered if he knew how much
trouble he had caused how much trouble
he was in now
i really wanted my father to see the
goat suit i didn't realize he had gone
scott went on glanting at his mother
with a faintly approving smile
i thought it would freak him out a
little make him think he was seeing a
ghost or something
i just wanted him to know that things
would never be forgotten
he sighed and slumped back down in his
chair clearly exhausted
it was nearly 3 am all saints day that's
all he said
there was another long profound silence
in the room all julia could hear was
scott's short hitching breasts
and the clank of metal bars somewhere
far away she looked at her son
suddenly reappeared after so long
seemingly back from the dead
as she thought of all he had done the
lives he had ruined over something that
may or may not have occurred
she had a horrible vision of him his
face bloated in white above the glossy
black fur of his goat costume
resting peacefully and eternally at the
bottom of the stream beneath the
woodboro bridge
perhaps she thought that was where he
really was now and where he really
belonged
perhaps the boy in front of her was
merely an imposter still in costume even
beneath the one he'd taken off
a changeling a devil she was still
thinking along these lines when wright
stood
gestures got to his feet and cuffed the
boy's hands behind his back
when he intoned charges that included
making a false report
obstructing justice possessing false
identification
julia went home alone once again
wondering if a black goat would be
lurking in the shadows beneath the
bridge in her dreams
jack thought there had been a dead woman
on the bed a few moments before
but when he blinked once twice keeping
his eyes closed for longer on the third
blink imagining her lying there
then opened them again he realized he
must have been mistaken there was no one
there
he even placed a tentative hand on the
covers pink sheets very feminine not
like him at all
they weren't even warm he got up and
went to the window
the curtains were fussy too white lace
and he scowled as he pushed them aside
he couldn't see anything through the
glass it was just dark not dark like
night but dark like death
no light coming from anywhere no stars
or moon
he let the curtains drop silently back
into place
he thought he would go out for a while
he felt very strange and couldn't
remember what had happened just now or
even earlier in the day
the room around him seemed wrong it was
familiar and somehow not familiar
like a place he had been in as a child
or in a dream but partially forgotten
the door wasn't locked although it had
many locks on it none were fastened
he opened it and found himself in a
hallway lit with one dim yellowish bulb
with no
shade a bulb that looked like it might
have come from thomas edison's
laboratory
fly specked and grimy with dust there
was a door just like the one he'd come
from
directly across the hall jack could see
that there had once been a number on it
but it had fallen or been pulled off
some time long ago
there was still a faint unreadable ghost
of the figures remaining but to him they
looked like characters in some alien
language
he closed his own door behind him and it
sounded blasphemous
as soon as he had done so the door
across the hall sprung open and a squat
disheveled woman stood there
meaty hands grasping her wide hips stop
banging that door
she squealed in a voice as tiny as her
girth was enormous
where's your mother jack blanched he
didn't know this woman
had she always lived there across the
hall she looked like his mother but that
couldn't be
his mother was at home in the apartment
behind him lying on the bed on those
girlish pink sheets
jack shook his head to clear it he felt
very muddled i don't know
he said and it came out a bit garbled
but the reply seemed to satisfy the
woman
because she immediately retreated back
into her own apartment slamming the door
much more loudly than jack had
the stairwell was steeped in shadow and
jack nearly lost his footing walking
down them
at one point he thought a huge bug ran
across the toe of his shoe
but in the dimness it was hard to tell
the floor below the one he'd left looked
much the same
with the same ancient light bulb
illuminating the same dispirited doors
with the same ghostly gobbledygook where
the apartment numbers used to be
jack thought the place should stink
looking like it did but he didn't smell
anything
he was heading for the next stairwell
when he heard the creak of another door
opening behind
him he wasn't going to stop he didn't
know any of the people that lived here
but he found himself stopping anyway and
turning toward the noise
another woman was peeking through the
crack she was young
and jack thought she was pretty although
he couldn't see much of her face
her hair looked red and she was smiling
at him
hey jack she said and she sounded
buttery velvety
he smiled back at her a bit uncertainly
he didn't know her name
how did she know his but he said hello
back to her
because it seemed rude not to you should
come in for a while
she said and jack could still see only a
sliver of her face in the crack of the
doorway
um some other time he said or at least
that's what he thought he said
his own voice sounded odd to him echoed
with parts of words transposed with
other parts
just for a while she wheedled her smile
growing larger
she opened the door a little wider and
jack could see her whole face now though
her body was still in shadow
she was beautiful with round blue eyes
like a doll's
her teeth were very white in the dim
hallway
i'm going out jack said and his ears
heard nothing but a melange of
inscrutable syllables
what was the matter with him he thought
he must be dreaming but it didn't feel
like a dream
he felt awake enough he was just
confused
or perhaps he was overtired what had he
been doing earlier what time was it now
night surely it had been dark outside
the window upstairs
he couldn't remember anything except
thinking that there had been a dead
woman on the bed in his apartment
or was it his apartment and there hadn't
been a dead woman there after all had
there
he put his hand to his head as if he
could massage the truth from it
maybe he should go back upstairs to
check or to rest until morning when
everything would be clearer
you can't go out there said the
red-headed woman in the doorway
she was still smiling and her voice was
still kitten soft
but now her doll's eyes seemed predatory
she opened the door fully and jack saw
that she was completely naked
her fleshy body shaved and pale he
looked away
panicked but he could still see her in
the corner of his vision
she was moving toward him her nudity
particularly obscene in the hallway
under the dirty yellow light where
anyone might see her she didn't seem to
care
just kept coming closer her breasts
seemed gigantic
her mouth stretched too wide her lips
too scarlet
jack thought he would die if she touched
him then wondered why he had thought it
he shuffled away still not wanting to
appear rude but at the same time
realizing how ridiculous that was
his gaze flickered to the other door on
the landing and he telepathically willed
someone to open it
to see her and to break the spell that
her nakedness was weaving over him
and then much to his surprise someone
did open it
the man was skinny like a junkie all
knees and elbows and tattered jeans
three sizes too big for him and a white
tank top that hung on him like a flag of
surrender
his head was shorn his eyes glassy he
looked at the naked redheaded woman as
if there was nothing unusual about the
situation at all
he sniffed nodded to acknowledge her
nodded again to jack
without speaking he came out into the
hall as jack watched the junkie went
right up to the naked woman and grabbed
her breast and his bony hand
kneading it hard his jaw was set as
though in fury
she was still smiling and now began
making low moaning noises in the back of
her throat
then the man slapped her across the face
the impact like a gunshot
and jack stepped forward to intervene
trying to form the word hey
and not sure if he succeeded but the
woman wasn't angry
she just smiled even more savagely jack
began to back away from them
trembling neither noticed him they
stared only at each other
their eyes like four glints of some hard
metal
the woman whirled on her heel her red
hair flying out behind her like a bloody
banner
and she took the junkie by the hand and
dragged him behind her grinning all the
while
the pair of them disappeared into her
apartment and the door slammed behind
them
jack stood looking at the closed door
for what seemed like forever his stomach
nodded
this place was a crazy house he felt the
panic rising again like the mercury in a
thermometer
and in that moment he needed to get out
of there away from the dingy light and
the bugs and the lunatics that inhabited
the building
trying to keep his self-control for just
a little longer i'll be out on the
street soon he thought
walking along the normal sidewalks with
the normal people and i never have to
come back here again
even if my mother does live here i never
have to visit her i'll just go outside
and never come back in
he hurried down the stairs to the lowest
floor taking the steps two at a time
seeing another even bigger bug but not
caring just ignoring it jumping over it
the bulb had burned out on the bottom
floor and the hull was bathed in shadows
jack wasn't aware that there were so
many shades of dark there were windows
there
one on either side of the entrance the
blessed entrance to the street
but there was nothing outside the
windows just a black or black
the same as he'd seen from the window
upstairs the red-haired woman's words
came floating back to him
you can't go out there and he was afraid
but then he scolded himself
he was just being ridiculous of course
he could go outside the door was right
there with the world on the other side
of it
and all he had to do was march over
there and open the door and that would
be the end of it
he got to the bottom of the steps his
shoes clanging on the corrugated risers
it was very dark but he could still see
the other door in the hallway
there was only one apartment on the
first floor just to the left of the
entrance
the exit jack thought i'm going out of
it now so it's the exit
the door of the apartment didn't have a
number on it and there wasn't even a
hint of one as there had been on the
other doors
for some reason this bothered him the
door was open a crack
and this bothered him even more so much
in fact that he couldn't bring himself
to cross the lobby in front of it
the image came to his mind unbidden of a
huge tentacle or some such monstrous
thing
slithering from that crack and wrapping
itself around his leg or even his neck
and pulling him toward the door as he
kicked and screamed the people upstairs
wouldn't help him
he knew that somehow he had to get to
the exit
he drew himself up and took a deep
breath he was going to have to run for
it hope that he was faster than whatever
was lurking in the wedge of darkness and
the crack of the door of the only
apartment on the bottom floor
he glanced nervously over at it was that
a movement there in the shadows
stop it he thought just stop it there's
nothing in there
someone had probably gone out and left
the door ajar that was all
or someone's watching you his inner
voice whispered
right there in the dark the whites of
their eyes wet and shining
stop it gathering his strength he
sprinted for the exit
the lobby seemed so much bigger as he
ran than it looked before and he kept
thinking he was about to reach the door
when it was still yards away
he kept checking over his shoulder as he
ran sure that a slimy hand was even now
preparing to clamp down on the back of
his head
a hand like a corpse's hand covered with
worms and maggots in grave mud
the crack in the door seemed to yawn as
wide as a canyon
at last his fingers scraped the wood of
the exit door and it was real and solid
and wonderful
he pressed his face against it and let
out a laugh that sounded high and shaky
the laugh of a hysterical madman the
doorknob was slick and cold
and though jack had a moment when he
thought it wasn't going to turn in the
end the door swung inward he stood on
the threshold and stared out
there was nothing there no steps no
street no buildings
no trees or sky just a black like a
velvet shroud closing around the face
suffocating blinding jack made to step
out into the blackness and found that he
could not
the darkness was a solid thing a wall of
nothing
without being aware of it a keening
noise began in jack's throat
and he began slapping at the wall with
his palms over and over again
until they were red and stinging but
still he beat at the barrier and he
keened
and the king became a whale that bounced
off the solid blackness and right back
into his nose his mouth his lungs
a never-ending loop of call and response
finally he stopped and slid to the floor
the pain in his hands a far away echo
the darkness in the hallway of the
apartment building didn't seem quite so
dark now
and jack could see the bugs crawling all
over the walls and floor
enormous bugs with hairy legs and
questing antennae
and beady black eyes like obsidian
marbles they became one with the shadows
moving among them and between them the
door of the numberless apartment was
wide open now and inside was more of the
black from outside a slice of it in the
shape of a man-high rectangle
he heard a voice calling him from inside
a voice that seemed made of the darkness
the kind of voice that death would have
if it could talk
it was calling his name and then other
voices joined in until it was a chorus a
cacophony
whispers and screams and seductive purrs
calling him like a million radio
stations all tuned in at once
jack got to his feet and shuffled toward
the open door there was nowhere else to
go
he knew that now ever since he had woken
and seen the dead woman on the bed
he had known that things would have to
end this way his shoulder slumped in
resignation
he crossed the threshold and swallowed
the darkness whole let it swallow him
utterly the room was the same
the pink sheets the white lace curtains
that fluttered in a gentle breeze
he couldn't feel the sun was out and a
square of blue sky
peaked through the lace the shafts of
sunlight falling in stark strips across
the figure of the woman on the bed
the squat fat woman with the perpetual
scowl that was now slack and powerless
jack didn't know how long he'd been
sitting there next to his mother
didn't know how long it had been since
the last breath had left her body
he touched her arm still warm but going
clammy
he choked back a sob he had always lived
here with his mother
since he was a little boy in this
building with the bugs and the yellow
light bulbs that flickered and never
worked on the first floor
he knew no other home was close to no
other person
of course there was always darlene the
redheaded girl on the second floor
but she didn't know he existed not
really he dreamed of her
watched her come and go but she was
older and he was just a child
jack wondered if she would help him now
he rose from his chair
looking down once at the empty husk that
had been his mother until just a few
minutes ago
when the electrical impulses that had
animated the meat had ceased to function
forever
jack looked out the window again at the
beautiful day birds chirped as though
nothing sad
had ever happened and never would happen
sighing he crossed the floor
unfastened all the locks on the door and
ran out into the hall
calling for someone to come
you